car
ああああああ
goo
8僕あのすごいゲームなぁ大好きなんですよね
あの子供の頃から例えば小学校の時となんかはあの後毎日ネギその端友達の家に行って
あの毎日8月のゲームは狩りをしていたり立ったりとか
いまでもその
二山さんの高校生とかと一緒にいまして
あのゲームをやったりなったりとか
リマつのゲームがいスポーツって言われてるんですよね
要はそれについて少しお話ししたいと思います
これはの実際に
どれも県であの2016年から開催してます
とても桂馬は青いっていうイベントなんですけれども
こちらのイベント結構その
ネギやの3回ぐらいでやってるんですけれども
あの県外グランド3カ所の結構色イベントになってまして
これがその越冬
今年の9月に実際に実施したイベントの様子なんですけれども
あの街の県外のプレイヤー達っていうのも結構なその妻ものが来ているっていう感じし
て
この時なんかはあのちょうど1週間前に関東で行われた大会でも上位のプレイヤーたち
が何も来られていていたり立ったりとか
それこそその数ヵ月前にあったアメリカで
すごい有名な世界大会で非常に入賞されたようなプレイヤーなんかも参加している中で
あの
また山健ニール僕のお友達ばにどんな感じっていう話を聞いたらこのやっぱり来てる
プレイヤー私がすごく強くて
ても下手ないっていう感じで聴いても聴いてたんで
ん
あのこういった感じでそのトーナメントが辛抱していく様子を見て
やっぱり感想のプレイヤーたち強いなあっていう風に僕らは見てたんですよ
でせっかくなんでそのあの
優勝が気になったという
せっかく遠方から来ていただいたのでまあせっかくなので挨拶化粧かなっていうので
挨拶者分
どこからきょこられたんですかっていう話を聞いたら夏の優勝者の方は
富山県の及ぶ時間きたって言われた
僕ら自身もそういったプレイヤーがとへ向けに違うっていうのは本当に知らなくて
比嘉話によるとオンラインのネットワーク上でのランキングは当時1位だったくらい
だったんですよね
こういったことが結構その今
結構起きるんですよ
というのも
あの写真に載っているようなまあこういう感情はその実際にその
オンラインではなくてオフラインという実際の環境下であのみんなで体験入れないをし
てまー顔を突き合わせですねやったりするんですが
普段っていうのは
家とかでそのインターネットに接続してオンラインであのかつ
活動というかもゲームをするっていうのは今主になっている中で
あの
クリアとしもそれぞれあの実名ではなくて半分ネームで活動するっていうのがいま
まあ結構主流になっている中で
なんていうか実際のこういったイベントしに出てこないとあの人はどこどこの人なんだ
とか
あぁこの人はこういった人だったんだとかっていうのが見えなかったりもするんですよ
ね
最近そのはゲームのプレイヤーたちがありともうあのお話しする機会が増えたんです
けれども
このゲームに対しの先入観っていうところ
少しお話しますとやっぱりそのゲームというのはもうすごいのめり込んでいるような人
たちを想像していただければと思うんですけれども
家とかでその引きこもってコツコツゲームをやっているみたいな
まあそういった衣装も結構持たれている方達って多いと思うんですよ
は全然それは間違いじゃなくて僕自身もそういった感じですがゲームするんですけれど
も
あの今よりているのはそのリースポーツっていうのは基本的にはその対戦するような
ゲームのことを指しているんですよね
でその中にはあの後銀とかでチームを組んで5体構成戦うような
ゲームもあればあの1対1で個人で戦うゲームもあります
例えばその剛体号で戦うやのチームゲームであれば
こんな感じその
mariko つけてなどヘッドフォンして
あのー
味方のみんなとその
コミュニケーションを取りながら例えばその左から敵が来ているとか
このためにいるところとかに行こうとかっていう感じでまぁコミュニケーション取っ
たり行ったりとか
それこそのゲームのプレイをする前にはどういった作戦であのー
戦っていくかっていうのも話し合いもしますしウォータ後はここが良かったよねとか
悪かったよねっていう反射もします
あの
1対1で戦うような個人型のゲームであってもあの
は練習相手と試行回数を重ねて練習することによって
あの自分の弱いところとか強いところっていうのを引き出してもらって
もそこを伸ばしてあげちゃったとか拡幅するという感じでゲームもやっています
この写真の後実際にあの
一対一でやってるようなゲームなんですけれども本当に後ろまでもみんなが集まってを
は交渉が言うとかっていうアドバイスが飛び交いながらやっているという感じですね
多分そのゲームをされたことがある方だったらその実際にいたような経験体が決行され
ていると思うんですよ
例えばその何がの友達に9てゲームをしたり立ったりとか
ゲームセンターにてゲームをしたり
まあいいルっていうのがありますよね
他にもその
1人で遊ぶようなゲームもあると思うんですけれどもそういったゲームなんかでも
例えば
あのー明日ここまでクリアしたから友達とか
飯島してあげようとか
あのここをクリアできたから教えてあげようとか行けなかったから
オーバー車教えてもらおうかなとかやっぱりそういったところを考えると
まぁそこには絶対の人っていうのがいたと思うんですよ
そういったあのー
esports 電話やれていますけれどもそういった本当にレースとなりはコミュニ
ティっていうのは
ホント昔からあったんですよね
実際にその
富山県内で
今からそうですね10年ほど前に
あの
ゲームの愛好家たちが集まってそのゲームセンターを借りて
あのゲーム大会をやってたんですよ本当に完全に皆
趣味でやってるんで
あのなんというかそれぞれのスタッフのみのボラン系で
やって本当にコミュニティ主催のイベントになるんですけれども
そのイベントが
ピアノん
そうですね人以外のイベントで
3階目のそんなミニしてあのひとつのゲームセンターに500人ものプレイヤーがにょ
前後から詰まったんですよね
やっぱりそのゲームセンターでその500人ものプレイヤーを1日でこんな見つけ式で
砂漠っていうのはとてもじゃないですけど相当時間がかかるっていうのでそれ以降は今
米海からは東京で開催されている今も続いている
イベントになっているんですけれども
あの今お話ししたようなそういうのってたぶん一つの例にしか過ぎないんですよね
今までそのビデオゲームが
こいつ長いが普及されてきた中で
あのもうすぐ入ったのは
ユーロあると思いますしもちろんさんの楽しむ方であったりとか
希望かによって違いますけれども
さっき旅のもとに今井スポーツって言われている中で下地っていうのはほんとにもう
僕もあった状態なんですよね
僕はノータイム鍵付前戯
イベントをやったりだったりとかあとはそのプロチームをすべて
実際にその選手を開い階の第五回とかにあの
通用してもらったりとかしてますけれども先ほどお話ししたような例も含めて
もうそこの地方のた今現実からもうそれほどの
下地みたいなもの
過ごし関心ですよ
それでいま
なんていうか日本のスポーツはすごく意外と比較したら遅れがちだっていうのすごいは
言われます
言われるんですよね
でもそれに対して僕はすごくなんていうかギャップを感じていまして
あの今お話ししたようなこれほどになんていうか素晴らしい
下地がある中で
本当にそのいスポーツていますの商品であったりとか市場規模とか
のそこばかりにも比較されていますけれどもそれだけ害すことではないんで
お水総合的に見るとむしろ日本はもういスポーツ p ところ歌手の
持って進んでいるんじゃないかな世論ここは思いますね
6本当にいいスポーツ e スポーツともに言われていますけれどもやっぱりそのゲー
ムって楽しいですよね
楽しくなかったら家もやらないと思うんですよ
まーす付かないというか
そんな中でその
そうですね
まあ設けてもやっぱり楽しいから練習をしますしその一つの目標に対して
あの練習したりとか非常に向かって取り組むという過程が面白かったりもするんですが
それであのー
人間の何時がほんの4回ところもあると思うんですよね
そんな感じで皆さんもぜひ一緒にゲームをやっていきましょう
ありがとうございましたーーー